[Music]
let's go to steve in tampa hey steve
what's up
hey dr john how are you brother having
me oh man thanks for calling in what's
up dude
well so the the issue is my
ex-wife and i we have two kids uh 50-50
okay and she's she's dating a man with a
long and recent criminal history of
domestic violence of multiple women
not to mention robbery so
the question is how do i handle this oh
my gosh man what have you tried
uh tried everything
i've tried
um her family i've tried lawyers
i've talked to my therapist about it i
mean i even
i even offered to set her up with an
online dating profile just to show her
that she can do so much better yeah
um but nothing
huh how old are your kids
six and nine
geez louise man
is she at a place where she's bringing
this this
um
idiot around them
oh yeah i mean they're they're on the
verge they're probably gonna get married
soon
okay what was your give me a couple of
the
some of the advice you received what'd
your counselor say
uh she had a good suggestion to create
um like a safe like a password for the
kids like an emergency
um
it's like a safe word like if they ever
just need me to come pick them up no
questions asked that is a hundred
percent that'd be my number one thing
that's excellent or that'd be my number
two thing what else um did she recommend
um i think that was the big one um
i mean there's you know at this point
there's nothing that occurring is not
gonna get changed and that's not that's
not my my role what'd the attorney say
about my concern
i talked to four attorneys and they all
said there's nothing that i can do you
gotta wait till something happens
yeah it's all reactive
um that even in the extreme case of like
if he was a convicted child molester
that there's
that would be even a stretch
like none of them gave me a legal path
forward
wow
unbelievable
um
i'm just i'm thinking i'm putting myself
in your situation our kids are
relatively the same age
and there's nothing
nothing more important to me than the
safety and security of my kids both
psychologically physically
all that right
and so i'm just sitting here
not as a as a podcast guy or a radio guy
but just as dad to dad man and
that feeling of powerlessness
i'm aching with you that's what i'm
telling you i'm heartbroken with you
brother
um
how are you doing how are you feeling
before i start running my mouth here
oh it's like you said it's just
powerlessness um
i mean i know there's things i can't
control i know that i can't feel prevent
uh i can't keep them safe from every
danger out there but this just seems
this just seems imminent and i'm just
supposed to just take it accept it
yeah that's that's a tough pill to
swallow
is your wife interested in
does she like the joint custody
arrangement is this a power move for her
um
well played
you know
that's a whole different rabbit hole um
there's probably going to be some
revisiting of that down the road like if
you went to her today and said i'm
willing to take 100
take these these burdens from you and
you can go live your life would she say
great or would it be more of a how dare
you
it would be hard area okay all right
okay
oh man all right so here's where i'm
starting if i'm you
number one
i'm gonna deal with i want to deal with
you internally
and
also then transition to the limited
resources that you have okay
number one dealing with you
is being constantly aware and i'm glad
you're seeing somebody you got to get
some buddies in your life
but being constantly aware
of the feeling of powerlessness because
that comes out in us differently there's
genetics there's there's the models we
grew up with there's all kinds of ways
that comes out but for some of us
powerlessness comes out in depression
some of us comes out in anxiety some of
it comes out in rage and anger and we
snap or we just fume some of it we end
up becoming addicted to scrolling so
think about what's happening you know
nationally internationally with the
covet stuff right that feeling of
powerlessness comes out of of us in all
these random ways
and none of them are helpful
right
and so it's constantly knowing okay now
i've found myself in a situation where
my body is sensing it's not in control
here's what i'm gonna do about it okay
so that's that's an important thing is
keeping yourself well in this process
and not letting yourself get down a hole
does that make sense
yep okay
so here's number two i think your
counselor is way onto something and i
would recommend going one step further
so
you you've you listened to this show
ever you know i am radically
radically against phones for kids
um i think those things are i think they
are destructive there's not a redeeming
quality about a kid with a cell phone
none
and in your case i think it might be
worth visiting
getting them some sort of connective
device
whether that's the um the gabaphones is
that the ones that that have some sort
of protective they don't just open up
the internet to a seven-year-old right
but there's got to be some connection
between you and your kids
that then allows them to have some sort
of safe text safe word safe calls a safe
way to communicate with you
maybe even a safe uh well seven's really
young to start recording people without
him knowing and i don't know your
state's laws but some way they can
connect with you do they have phones or
devices now
yeah they have devices okay all right
tablets all right so shame on you and
good for you all right
so
um some way they can communicate with
you
that leads me to number two and i would
explore this with your counselor
but there has to be a reality check so
i'm a hundred percent against speaking
negatively about like x's even when
they're bonkers even when they're
destructive
but that doesn't mean that we don't tell
the truth factually
okay so i would have conversations with
my kids about
and this is a this is a good practice
regardless right
there are
scary people in the world
and some of them are scary because
they're loud
some of them are scary because they hit
other people some of them are scary
right you see where i'm going and this
is going to be age appropriate share
don't scare but
we're going to have a conversation with
their kids that there is scary people
out in the world and i'm gonna begin
having conversations about what do you
do
how do we respond to this
and i want your kids to know they
respond by calling you
they respond if you're not available by
calling 9-1-1
and be very explicit about
sometimes we get so scared that we don't
want to move
and that's really important that you
reach out to daddy then
sometimes we get so scared and somebody
says if you tell anybody you're in big
big trouble
or i'm going to hurt somebody then you
really have to tell dad
you really have to tell me right and
having this conversation
is is it's it's um it's insane the fact
that you're even having to have this
conversation right
um and that's where you find yourself
and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna begin to teach our kids and have
conversations with their kids about this
in a
less pathological example
my kids know we have a 9-1-1 rule
if we're at a store or if we're at a
restaurant and i look at my son and say
this is a 9-1-1 situation we need to go
he knows ask no questions
ask no don't look around we get up and
we walk out of the restaurant and that's
happened once
um and again this some of this is
because i grew up with a homicide
detective and a swat guy as a as a
father and i run around with police
officers in the middle of the night
dealing with tragedy so some of this is
me being paranoid paranoid right
but also i want to have a situation with
him that knows
we got to go now and not his normal why
i'm still eating my burger right and so
this is just an extension of that
conversation
an invite every time your kids come home
tell me about what y'all did how was it
what were the good stuff what was the
what were the b what was the best times
what were the worst times tell me about
a time you were scared tell me about a
time you felt brave and i want you to
make that a part of the regular rhythm
of your conversation with your kids and
again this is insane that you're having
to do this right but we're gonna have
this regular rhythm of this conversation
so that not if but when something
happens
it's a part of your regular rhythm it's
not going to be this weird new you know
you hear me talk about talking with your
kids about sex if you wait to have a big
don't don't do it hey kid sex talk it's
gonna be a disaster if you make talking
about sex a regular rhythm in your house
then when your kid asks a question it's
not weird it's just part of the
narrative it's just part of the
interaction in your home same thing
we're doing here
um
but i want to have some sort of norm for
them calling you
is that fair
yes thank you um are you allowed and i
don't know the the laws in maryland are
you allowed to text your kids and check
in with them when they're with mom or do
you have to cut off communication
oh i'm allowed to communicate with them
anytime i want okay
so
um
i've had some interactions with folks
when they were going into meetings and
they were worried about safety and i've
sat outside their meeting
there was no threats or i've called
police officers to come sit outside of a
meeting when i was gonna have a
conversation with somebody that might be
volatile
um and we had things like
i'll just text you punctuation
i'll text you a question mark or a
period or a hyphen
and it would it will look benign to
anybody else
but it might just be
you you say hey i'm just gonna start
texting you a couple of times you have
to respond
regardless and i'm gonna text you a
thumbs up and you or that may be a
little bit on the nose but i'm going to
text you an abc
and if everything's going great you text
me a def or whatever the thing is but
y'all come up with some sort of check-in
system
that would be benign and again we're not
talking about secrets and we're not
telling your kids all right we got to do
this and not tell anybody
um
but just texting them hey i love you and
if things are going great say i love you
back and if they're not going great say
i love the astros or whatever the thing
happens to be right
um how does that sound
uh that sounds like a really good idea
okay thank you
um hey know that my heart's with you man
and
the moment something happens
please don't hesitate i know you won't
you've checked with four lawyers you're
you're on top of a dad
don't hesitate
um sometimes there's some hesitation
like well that one wasn't that bad that
one wasn't this i don't want to blow
their lives up
mom is making a really um
damning decision here man and i'm sorry
you're in the middle of it and
it's just gonna require some extra
vigilance and making sure that you're
okay but uh man thank you so much for
your call brother and we'll be thinking
about you'll be with you man and for
those of you who
have an ex
and
you're
you're you're post-divorce and you're
dating
and you're with somebody and you think
man like this person's got these major
red flag flaws
but they love me and they've quote
unquote change whatever
be so
so careful about how you bring your kids
and
into your life and into your life kids
lives
be very careful man
your kids deserve more than than you
being
with somebody who's an abuser
and quite frankly you deserve to be with
somebody who's more than abuser